i'm daniel ehrenberg i wanted to talk
about up-and-coming standards in
javascript modules
so we have javascript modules natively
in
no the web and node.js and
i'm going to talk about six new features
coming
to standards how standards work and how
to get involved
so es modules are standardized in ecma
tc39 ecoma is a standards committee
that's part of
um you know it was a standards committee
ekman international it's based in geneva
and tc39 was the 39th
technical committee inside of ekma
we work in meetings
normally in person now they're just
video calls as well as github
we have a four stage process for for new
language features
in stage one an idea is under discussion
in stage two we decide as a committee we
want to do this
and we have a first draft at stage three
there's a final draft
and it's ready to go for implementations
so before stage three will often have
early prototype implementations
especially in transpilers and polyfills
and after stage three we'll have
implementations that come to more
conservative environments
like web browsers and and typescript
and once something has two fully
full implementations and tests then we
can promote it to stage four
and it becomes part of the draft
standard so proposals in tc39 advance
by consensus the committee agrees the
committee comes to consensus
on a proposal meeting the requirements
for the next stage
and being something that we want to add
to javascript
so you can join tc39 by joining ekwa we
unfortunately don't have
any uh member organizations from
israeli companies or organizations and
it would be great to
get more involvement there but whether
you're a member or not
everyone can participate in github
so tc39 javascript doesn't exist in a
in a vacuum i mean in a way in a way it
does because the javascript standard
itself
doesn't know how to do any input and
output
instead they integrate with
input and output by what we call host
environments
such as html so the html standard
tells javascript how to import modules
how to load them
by doing a you know an http get command
so html is actually an integral part to
how
javascript modules work the html
standard
is maintained by an organization called
what wake
or actually it's a it's a stretch to
call what we can organization because
it's very
kind of informally
informally based but it's in github
it has all issues and and pull requests
in github and no meetings
and just like tc39 everyone can
participate on github
the criteria to land a change is that it
requires support
from at least two browser engines and no
strong opposition
as well as a good review by
by the html editors and tests just like
tc39 also requires tests
and at this point unfortunately we're
left with only three
browser engines standing chrome safari
and firefox
so let's let's talk about these new
features
so top level await one thing that's a
little bit annoying about async
functions is that
uh async await is that you have to put
the await inside of an async function
with this feature with javascript
modules you can use a weight
outside of an async function the
semantics of this
is that it means that loading the module
is awaiting
so it's like running a module is like
running a big
async function if you import modules
that
have an await at the top level then it
runs all the weights from each of the
different modules in parallel
and so this can be used to coordinate
initialization
if you import something that awaits
something then
that will run just once and it will run
before the things that come later in the
module but it will allow other kinds of
initialization to happen in parallel
so this proposal is at stage 3 and tc39
and it's merged in html there
you know there were two different parts
to the specification
there are several implementations that
are that are complete more in progress
and some some implementations actually
know how to execute this code or
transpile it away whereas other
implementations
just know how to uh parse it and allow
it through
there's a lot of different things in the
javascript tool chain that had
have to have some kind of support for a
language feature to
to really be usable everywhere
so every time we make a tc39 proposal
there's what we call an explainer or a
readme
that describes the point of the proposal
the the motivation
and at a high level what it's about they
also have specification text
we use a markup language called xmarkup
it's sort of like
html and markdown put together
and we describe how exactly the
specification changes
in addition in html tests
to nail down the details and these pull
requests make changes
against the main html specification
and then html also there's some there's
some automatic infrastructure to to
generate these
these nice diffs so
to make top level await happen it
requires
designing the specification outreaching
to
different uh stakeholders
and making tests at these different
levels of the exact semantics
and implementing it in different
environments
another feature coming is json modules
so node.js has supported
json modules that you can import for for
a long time
you can make it work with with webpack
the the semantics that we decided on for
the standard
is that when you import json you get one
big json object in the default export
rather than individual named exports
which is important because not all the
json
keys in the object could even be named
named exports it doesn't really map uh
when we were
thinking about how when i say we i mean
in the the web standards world when when
json modules were proposed
to be added to the web mozilla and
apple realized that there was a
potential security
problem if you import a json module
from some kind of less trusted source
you might expect that it would only be
data but if we had a normal import
statement then it would have just as
much right to run code
so for json modules we require that they
have this assertion
that they're asserting that they're that
they're json
so these assertions were generalized
further to import assertions
so in every module import statement
there's a there's sort of a key value
pair that could
list assertions the only assertion we're
defining right now is type
but more assertions could be defined
later they're built into the module
loader
not that you can add your own assertions
and these are required for
for this security mitigation but the end
result is
that json modules will be usable equally
in in all these different environments
with this uh slightly more verbose
syntax and so this is
in stage 3 and tc39 and out for review
and html
and i'm excited about this this effort
in addition to json modules
expect to see css and html modules
coming where css modules
let you import a style sheet which you
can then apply
to a shadow root for scoped
for scope css manipulation and html
modules may work for
templating in a way that's built into
the browser templated components
though that's there's a bit more design
work needed there
another feature that that we've been
working on
in in standardization is module blocks
module blocks let you run more
javascript code in parallel
so to run a worker today
you know you can use web workers in the
web but also
in node.js now there's there's a worker
library built in
and these use message passing to
communicate
but the api for creating a worker
is based on passing in a
path there is
a modification to this api you can
specify that you want to import a module
but the module is is still specified in
another
you know their file with module blocks
we can have an inline module so that to
make a new worker
you don't need to make a new file and
this is exciting at least to me because
for a lot of applications it can be
difficult to break things into multiple
files
sometimes people have libraries that are
reused in different environments
and there's no clear way to break it
into multiple files that could be
deployed everywhere
and so a module block is a piece of code
that's independent of a particular
context
it could be used in the place where you
define it or it could also be used out
in a worker
but workers don't share anything with
the other
um with the with the place they were
launched from i mean they share
some structures but they have a
different javascript heap everything is
very
detached from one to the other so it's
important that there be no direct
object references from one to the other
so multiple blocks give
an independent piece of code that can be
shared
that means they don't close over
anything so they can't
reference things that are outside of the
multiple block they can just import
other modules
or reference the global object so
fundamentally with a multiple block
you can import it with dynamic import
and then get the the
exports object and then you can use it
you can see this example uses top level
weight
because if you're writing any little
async to weight code it's just natural
to use a weight at the top level
so multiple blocks are now at stage two
we just had a tc39 meeting last week
and the committee came to consensus on
bringing multiple blocks to stage two
and in tc39
um you know one way one way that the
committee could organize itself is the
committee takes on pieces of work
and then just everybody works on it we
in tc that are not have a champion model
so committee members can champion
or lead the work on a proposal
and they're responsible for you know
collecting everybody's feedback and
responding to concerns
and proposing the pushing the proposal
forward
so sherma developer relations
developer advocated google is the
champion of this proposal
so they have a readme they have spec
text
the specification text this is one of
the requirements for ch2
and one of the questions that people
ask often is can module blocks
be the solution to bundling can multiple
blocks let you bundle multiple js
modules into one
file because um you know when deploying
javascript applications
it's necessary to use bundlers to get
decent
uh startup performance
so maybe this could work
you know we could have these these two
modules that count in uppercase if you
want to use them
then we could await and import them
[Music]
so maybe it could work for bundling but
really it falls over pretty quickly
because then if you have a third module
that wants to use both of them
it's just not going to work when you try
to import count or uppercase
it's a reference error because these
multiple blocks do not close over
anything
actually we want a different concept for
bundling
for example we could call this
javascript multiple fragments so
you know you have fragments or ids in an
html page addressed by these hashes
what if we had that for javascript
modules as well so these are all in
you know some particular file and
you could import these modules
these inline multiple fragments by
a url that ends with a fragment
and that's this that's this basic idea
it's it's a very early draft i've not
fully written it up but i think if we
want to move forward with bundling which
lots of people have seen js
multiple blocks are excited about then
we might we might want to do something
like this
so it's it's a declarative way of
putting multiple modules in one
file and it's based on these url
fragments or
or ids a big advantage is that
it avoids the need for a fetch for a net
for an extra http
get every time you want to get a new
module
and it could all be understood by the by
the javascript engine
but really if you think about bundling
there's more to it
for example you want want to bundle in
css
or images or fonts and tools like
webpack know how to convert all of these
to strings or to base64 strings that you
could put in your javascripts
which has some serious efficiency
problems
but there's a lot more that bundlers do
like code splitting
figuring out the dependency graph for
your program
and when some resources are not needed
immediately at startup
maybe they're needed only when you go to
a specific route
then they can be downloaded later
but still the stuff that's downloaded
later is
in a certain limited number of chunks
rather than having to download each
resource one by one
another important function is cache
busting so making sure that
you can use long-lived caching modes
but at the same time when you have a
change you can
address that new resource it's also
important to make good use of the
browser cache so if you have
a javascript's
one of these compound files but only one
part of it changes and the other part
doesn't
then you would be kind of out of luck
for the cache but it would be great if
the caching could be somehow more
fine-grained
to reuse existing things that didn't
change
but at the same time bundlers are very
important because they help with
compression
they help it high quality compression be
used because the same
dictionary can be used across the
different resources that are
that are together in the same bundle
so a more complete solution that i've
been working on
is resource bundle loading so
a resource bundle is
a map from paths to a metadata
and payload so this metadata can be used
to represent mime types for different
kinds of resources
and the payload can be a response body
completely in binary
this this mapping is defined
using a language called sibor
which is a way of encoding binary data
structures that
is used heavily in ietf based standards
so to load a resource bundle
i'm suggesting that we use a kind of
manifest
that would be generated by tools to map
different resources to chunk ids and so
then when the chunk id is loaded
in the page the browser knows
when when one of these urls is loaded in
the page the browser knows oh
this comes from a resource bundle and i
need to load those chunk ids
so in this example the manifest says
that well this css file when i want to
load the css file is this chunk id and
then when i want to import these things
dynamically well i need those two
different chunk ids
and then these chunks on the server
contain these different resources
so on the initial load uh the only thing
that's needed initially
is you know button.css and page.css
so the browser loads this chunk for page
css
and the response actually has button css
in it also
so that also can get used from the
bundle
and that's what's loaded initially
when another resource is needed when you
import a then it says okay i need these
two chunks
and it can fetch those both at once
and then when b is needed this
chunk is already in cache so it only
needs the the other one
then say the page updates so say that
our
comment.js is the only thing that
changes from
alert to console.log
so only one chunk changes these
these contain a chunk list which
includes not just the thing with
a.js but also its dependency and so
these
hashes can be allocated similarly to how
you know etags or you know bundler
created
um cache busting works works today
where when the content changes the chunk
id changes and this chunk id is not
found in cache so it's the only one that
needs to be
fetched and only when something is
clicked
at the same time these these chunks are
allowed to contain multiple resources
for example the page and button
are in one single kind of chunk
so to compare javascript multiple
fragments versus resource bundles
there's a there's a number of different
axes of differences
uh one is text based you know the
the multiple fragments
are just part of the javascript grammar
so somehow it's easier to implement and
integrate that into things
but binary bundles have other advantages
that they can support other types that
couldn't be brought into the javascript
grammar
they require some new tools but then as
a benefit
they get efficient random access
another difference is at what level do
we want to virtualize resources
so resource bundles this general
solution that works for loading css or
images
they need to virtualize resources
at a lower level that what you could
call the fetch or the network level
so it's more expressive but it's also
somewhat more expensive whereas
javascript multiple fragments by
intercepting only javascript modules
could be cheaper in in some way but more
limited
there's also a question of how caching
works
resource bundles are cached at this
chunk id level whereas javascript
multiple fragments are stored in the
cache as a
as a single resource so not supporting
this more fine grained subsetting
and versioning with resource bundled
chunk ids you could change the chunk id
to represent a new version of the
resource whereas javascript multiple
fragments
don't have their own mechanism for that
and it's necessary to
have a different mechanism kind of on
top around the site
as as today there's no sort of built-in
web mechanism for for versioning
so there are many different trade-offs
when we think about about performance
if you think about individual resources
versus bundles
versus these two alternatives that i
just mentioned
we could think about the the waterfall
like
when you load one resource do you know
the other resources some resources
referenced from it is it is it going to
be sort of
some rolling rapids or is it going to be
a straight down waterfall when you're
looking at
all the resources that get loaded
hopefully the latter
there's this perv resource overhead like
how much does it cost in the browser and
in the server to load each thing
emulation with if you try to pretend
that everything is javascript that adds
some emulation costs
browsers have multiple processes inside
of them
and that that often determines the the
communication
and the the overhead from that can
determine the the loading performance of
pages
compression i mentioned before if you
bundle more things together then the
compression can be higher quality
also if the browser can understand more
of what's going on it can enable more
parallel processing
bundlers today obscure a bit what's
going on
they they have javascript logic that
puts in the different parts of the page
so some parts of the browser that work
today in a streaming way don't
don't work as well
so streaming when when browsers
download a page if they're able to
understand what's going on
then they can start interpreting it even
before the whole thing
comes in and i talked about code
splitting and chunking
so if we look at these different
alternatives
we can see these these trade-offs
with waterfall unless you use the right
prefetch commands which
you can use but aren't always deployed
individual resources
have a kind of worse waterfall than any
of these bundling options
they also have more overhead per
individual resource
because you need to do an extra http
uh get this is cheaper with http 2
and 3 but still it ends up being
important on large sites
resource bundles remove some of the load
but not
not all of it they still
they still go through certain browser
paths that would be expensive because
they're intercepting at this lower fetch
level
and this emulation cost is a real
problem with
certain ways that sites are deployed
whereas resource bundles may be able to
eliminate that and using individual
resources is
already is already optimal
in terms of avoiding this this emulation
so in the interest of time i'll skip to
the next
slide i want to mention that there is a
tension in general between compression
and caching
it's for compression you want to load
everything all together because then
they can share the compression
dictionary
with caching you want caching to be at a
fine granularity
to avoid duplicate loads so you want to
be able to
request just what you don't have in cash
but then
have everything that you're requesting
be be compressed together
so resource bundles kind of get the best
of both because
if we look back at examples like uh
loading this when we loaded a
these two chunks got loaded together so
they can be dynamically compressed
together
if they share some some code reducing
the size over the wire
at the end of the day i think we might
want both proposals both resource
bundles and module
fragments because of this per resource
overhead issue that we see with resource
bundles
so the per resource overhead issues
is kind of serious it's kind of
comes down to the core value of bundling
where bundling should be allowing us to
to bundle together many many resources
but javascript modules in practice today
seem to lead to the biggest blow up in
this number of resources
where you see 10 000 or tens of
thousands or more javascript modules
and then maybe you see hundreds at most
of other kinds of resources
so it kind of makes sense to
put special attention to optimizing the
per resource overhead of that
the other thing is that javascript
modules often break up
into packages or components that
make sense to cash together whereas
other things
maybe you want to break them down a
little bit more for caching
so i think we might want
both we might want to have resource
bundles that have module fragments
inside of them
so i'm running out of time but i want to
mention um
that privacy and the origin model are
really top-level concerns here
so brave published a blog post about web
bundles being harmful to content
blocking
and this this has to do with a few
different things this has to do with the
origin model
that it's important that the origin of
the site
represent something uh it has to do with
url semantics that
uh that
it the url is not just the origin but
the things that come
after the origin be somewhat meaningful
and so the the requirement in this
proposal is that when you use a resource
bundle
the bundle content should be named
individually by url
and it must be possible to fetch that
url individually
by that by that same name and get the
same result
and it's important that bundles don't
form a tracking vector
and that content blocking like ad
blockers still work with bundling
so i've been working with the help of
engineers in in brave and io to validate
that the design
of resource bundles maintains privacy
goals
and doesn't
[Music]
you know doesn't doesn't lead to these
problems it's very important to me that
we maintain these things
so
steps are to uh
develop module fragments and resource
bundles which are both very early stage
proposals
and module fragments in tc39 which
they're not even a proposal yet
and resource bundles in wicg
and eventually in what way html wicg
is a is a home for early proposals in
w3c
that handles intellectual property
matters
and uh in this process
it'll be really important to prototype
with implementations before things ship
people always talk about http 2 push
http 2 push was supposed to solve a lot
of these problems but it
but it kind of didn't and maybe that was
because people were too
eager to ship it before testing
so i think it's really important that we
test this in various environments before
shipping
and it's a it's a big project and it's
an early project and
if you want to get involved i'd be very
happy to hear from you
so yeah i i definitely encourage you all
if you if you have time and interest to
get involved in javascript standards
so the development the real technical
work is is done
online in github we have meetings to
discuss things and get more feedback
but almost all the ways to contribute
are
are through that and
it would be great to have help with
coming up with ideas dc39 has a forum
for that purpose
um documenting use cases working out
details of
of specifications
writing specifications and texts and
implementations
and uh yeah it'd be great to to work
together here
so thank you